das heißt also ich habe damit ich hätte
damit vor so ich würde vielleicht
jemanden den abonnenten schenken
der halt jetzt so ein roller
führerschein gemacht deswegen habe ich
gedacht das wäre ganz lustig und hey was
geht ab und herzlich willkommen bei
einem neuen video ja ich hoffe natürlich
geht's gut
die kamera ist bisher ohne wartung jetzt
muss es passen leute ich sehe gerade
schon ein ja ja das wetter dass ich gar
nicht gut aus filme hier an meinem
himmel da könnt ihr das ja sehen
ganz in schwarz kann man eine fliege
große fliege heute geht es ja nicht um
fliegen das ist jetzt gleich zu 100%
regnen wird ist nicht so gut weil wir
brauchen eigentlich draußen es stellt
sich natürlich die frage was machen wir
heute überhaupt ich habe jetzt wirklich
lange überlegt und herangearbeitet
endlich mal einen neuen pfad von der die
das günstigste rauszuhauen
und das war wirklich extrem schwer was
wirklich krass gewesen wäre ich hätte am
anfang so ein haus gehabt was irgendwie
also das grundstück wahrheit komplett
herunter gekommen und man konnte dieses
haus für extrem wenig geld kaufen also
es war eine so eine kleine hütte immer
das halt irgendwie das ein bisschen
renoviert und ich hatte mir das schon so
ein richtig großes projekt aus zumal
leider hat das nicht geklappt also ich
konnte es dann doch nicht haben deswegen
habe ich das format auch erstmal wieder
eingestellt sozusagen also bis jetzt
zumindest die auto leute unter euch
wissen natürlich noch ich habe vor
ungefähr eineinhalb bis zwei monaten
diesen alten e30 gekauft
und da kriege ich auch bis heute noch
vielen arien zu was denn damit ist und
ich glaube das muss ich erst mal ein
kleines update machen für alle damit ich
mal diese nachrichten nicht mehr ziegel
an alle die das jetzt nicht interessiert
es gibt einfach vor ok also seid mir
nicht böse dass ich jetzt wieder ein
bisschen was erzähle mir wirklich sehr
sehr viele leute geschrieben dass sie
super gerne dieses auto kaufen wollen
die angebote waren von 60 euro bis über
1800 euro was natürlich super viel geld
ist für ein auto und dann sind ja auch
die frage berechtigt die alex was ist
jetzt eigentlich mit dem auto und dann
muss ich ehrlicherweise sagen ich habe
mir auch gedacht so ewig gelbe dass wenn
man das auto hat so ein bisschen wieder
vor richtet also bisschen polieren neue
räder motorrad checken und so weiter und
ich war deswegen auch noch zweimal dort
also wo ich den herrn man bis man da was
wirklich was hat was ich euch dann
zeigen kann eine klare entwicklung
dieses autos oder verbesserungen nicht
dass jetzt mal ich kenne mich mit den
fachbegriffen da auch nicht so aus mir
leid das würde mich halt direkt mal
locker über zwei bis dreitausend euro
fonds und da hab ich gedacht puh das ist
auch ganz schön viel geld auch für mich
für ein video
also es ist schon krass ich hoffe das
versteht ja deswegen bin ich gerade so
in der zwickmühle was ich jetzt damit
macht irgendwas wie dazu sicherlich noch
kommen
ich weiß noch nicht wann aber in letzter
zeit hatte ich auch nicht so viel zeit
dazu muss ehrlich sagen das reicht jetzt
erstmal mit dem gelage wir haben nämlich
heute am nächsten kommt und zwar freue
ich mich darauf ich habe letztens bei
einem freund von mir so einen alten
rolle gesehen und den pferde heute nicht
mehr
und da kam mir die idee für wie viel ich
wohl diesen roller bekommen werden und
dann habe ich mal im internet gecheckt
was denn so oder so kreyßig die
günstigsten roller liegen auf anderen
plattformen fangen die so bei 200 an
hier haben wir jetzt einen roller für
100 der ist allerdings defekt 550 3500
400 also eher gut das hier ist nur so
ein tretroller also unter 200 euro
bekommt man da eigentlich nichts
deswegen bin ich mal gespannt was er
dafür haben möchte beziehungsweise ich
habe ja schon ein preis verhandelt wir
liegen gerade bei 70 euro weil er den
halt einfach nicht mehr haben möchte und
das war für mich halt eine extrem große
chance von weiteren part dieses format
ist weil ich meinen 70 euro kann man
halt easy x von video ausgeben und den
roller könnte ich dann vielleicht
irgendwie einem abonnenten schenken ist
oder nicht
doch gar nicht mehr auf der überhaupt
noch gut fährt das ist checken wir
gleich alles mal
und ja das machen wir im heutigen video
ich freue mich richtig wird sagen wir
fahren direkt mal los ich würde das viel
spaß bei den zuschauern und dann sehen
wir uns gleich im auto
also leute ich will jetzt hier
angekommen und zwar steht dahinter auch
schon der roller also genau vor mir was
ist das für ein modell weißt du das ok
also das ist vito dessen kollege von mir
der diesen roller jetzt lange gefahren
ist oder jetzt halt nicht mehr braucht
sagen haben so ich muss sagen an sich so
man sieht schon dass sie ein bisschen
älter ist aber du musst auch mal den
grund sagen warum du dir nicht mehr
brauchst und auch was damit nicht mehr
oder was nicht mehr voll
funktionstüchtig ist damit die leute
auch checken warum er jetzt nicht also
warum mit denen ich die haben
wahrscheinlich auch einen höheren wert
als jetzt 100 euro oder so verkaufen
weil der herd nicht mal richtig mit 20
km/h schnell nicht mehr schneller also
muss man irgendwas muss man wieder sage
ich mal flott machen sodass also denkt
wahrscheinlich etwas kaputt ja darauf
ich denke mal schon jetzt schon sicher
haben und hast das denn ich mal selber
abschrecken lassen oder du sagst einfach
du hast keinen bock drauf nach nur dann
kann ich das für mehr also ich weiss
letzte mal irgendwann mal hier da habe
ich dann gesehen und keine ahnung
bekommen wir halt die idee den die
abzukaufen 14.500 23 kilometer das geht
eigentlich oder das geht das nicht und
ich muss sagen ich kenne mich mit
rollern so wirklich das ist ein
teilgebiet da kenne ich überhaupt nicht
aus und für mich dass ich jetzt gar
nicht mal so viel an wobei man kann das
ja dann sag ich mal so wenn man es jetzt
beim auto vergleich auf x 3 rechnen weil
ich so weit er mit dem sollen durch
schon 50 km h
45.000 ich will damit jetzt gleich gerne
erfahren
ok dann müsst ihr euch so bedeute wir
sind jetzt gerade mal hier aufs land
gefahren also damit denn jetzt mal
fahren kann weil ich bin einmal mein
leben roller gefahren und das war im
urlaub aber jetzt gerade mal geguckt ich
habe ja bei mir im auto auch einfach
hoch waren sie bei 25 km/h glaube ich ja
also schneller ich hätte doch ein
bisschen mehr ist mehr als 20 bevor ich
jetzt aber damit fahre ist ja ganz
trocken hier ich kann mich im spiegel
film würde ich sagen wir mal kurz ein
kleines wie beim hallo liebe
car porn machen wir heute den rollatoren
mache ich mal ein paar geile aufnahmen
von dem ding da würde ich sagen
[Musik]
redwood shores
hier ist doch top oder nicht ja also ich
bin jetzt gerade mal kurz der runde
gefahren ich würde sagen wir können noch
mal kurz da runterfahren und dann kannst
du auch einmal von hinten filme oder ich
für dich weil die besatzung zu 2 drauf
und dann seht ihr dass er wirklich nicht
so schnell fährt also ich hab jetzt 25
km/h erreicht was trotzdem schnell weise
für mich so das hat schon spaß geworden
gesagt mit roland kann nämlich überhaupt
nicht aus ihr könnt mir gerne in die
kommentare schreiben
was daran kaputt sein könnte warum nicht
mehr so richtig auf speed kommt was habt
ihr denn früher geschafft ja also es
gibt ja auch mofa-fahrer 525 aber dass
wir in 50 jahren also 50 jahre 50 hat er
früher gern das wäre früher 50 haben
jetzt fehlt mir nur noch halt die 20
oder gerade die 25 gehabt vielleicht
doch langweilig bisschen leichter das
kann auch okay warte mal ich will noch
einmal fahren ja ein so dass der film
natürlich würde ich auch immer einen
helm tragen aber wir sind hier halt auch
so einem abgesperrten bereich war halt
auch nur 20 müssen noch klein doch nur
mal so ich glaube dass noch was kaputt
okay das noch ein zweites problem aber
ein schlechter sonst ganz gut
wer du bist kickstarter weil die
batterie das ist eine kleine batterie
und die hat halt nicht mehr so viel
power
die muss man immer so aufladen wie ein
handy reißen aber mit einem ruck
[Musik]
bis 20
das gerät also wenn man das jetzt auch
mal zusammenfasst der fährt maximal 25
km/h und springen auch nicht so gut an
ja kommen wir das heißt also ich hab
damit ich hätte damit vor so ich würde
vielleicht jemanden einen abonnenten
schenken
der halt jetzt so ein roller
führerschein gemacht deswegen habe ich
gedacht das wäre ganz lustig mit dem
gedanken jetzt dahinter was willst du
denn jetzt sagen so wurde keine
schmerzgrenze ich habe jetzt gesagt ich
habe 70 euro dafür höhere es dabei oder
weil ich meine schon also schon
schwierig aber soweit also keine ahnung
wie gesagt ich kann mich mit außerdem
jetzt ins internet stellt hier hast du
dann mehr dafür weil du musst ja
immerhin schreiben funktioniert nicht
funktioniert nicht mehr ganz so deswegen
ja ich denke ich würde ihn für 70 der
70er doch jan eis weil sonst mal kommt
weil ich bin ja dann würde ich sagen
freue ich mich ja meist gerät mein
erster roller der hammer haben leute und
ganz kurz eine sache noch wenn wir schon
mal dabei sind checkt auf jeden fall mal
seinen youtube videos oder musik video
nochmal zusammen gemacht habe ich ein
bisschen bei golfen ist der video
beschreibung verlinkt ist eigentlich
echt nice geworden wie gesagt ich würde
mich freuen wenn euch das mal anschaut
ja schicken
[Musik]
nicht
- zu müssen und an alle die jetzt gerade
irgendwie ein roller führerschein
bestanden haben oder was war ist er bei
den kann man ja erst recht zerfahren ne
125 ps der motor dann ja also ich sag
mal so wenn ihr einen führerschein dafür
habt oder den einfach haben wollte um
ihn wieder aufzuziehen auf 50 km/h aber
auf dem tacho steht doch sogar 120 ja
das war mal ganz für ganze dann lass dir
mal ein kommentar warum ihr die
richtigen seite für den roller und dann
lese ich mir die mal durch das war es
eigentlich noch also danke fürs
zuschauen würde ich sagen und wir sehen
uns morgen oder übermorgen kommt rein